predicted to be the worst storm in
decades eunice hit with devastating
winds reaching record speeds of up to
122 miles per hour
red weather warnings led to tragedy as
multiple lives were claimed
the first confirmed death in england was
here in haringay in north london a woman
in her 30s lost her life to storm eunice
after a tree fell on the car she was
travelling in
fatalities were also reported in
merseyside hampshire and ireland either
flying debris or falling trees were
responsible
while coastlines were battered eunice's
rage was felt across much of britain
struggling to withstand the weather
travel was brought to a halt train
services suspended roads treacherous and
planes struggling to land at heathrow
as the storm moved over england's
capital the severity of london's first
ever red weather warning became apparent
as winds ripped into the roof of the o2
there'd be downstream effects from the
course of the past 24 hours
trains cancelled across the country
berries cancelled transport disrupted
heavy snow as well across the north of
the uk so impacts will be felt for
several days to come as we try to return
back to normal with travel in particular
a yellow weather warning for wind
remains in place for parts of the south
and south wales the worst may be over
but the trail of destruction is
extensive and will likely cause more
disruption over the weekend aisha zahid
sky news